هذا ما يسميه العلماء
حرائق غيبوبة حرائق الغابات التي تنجو من
ثلوج الشتاء
وتشرع مرة أخرى في الربيع وهي
ظاهرة تضيف إلى تعقيد
تغير المناخ ، وجدت دراسة جديدة أنه
على الرغم من أن هذه مشكلة صغيرة
الآن
إلا أنها يمكن أن تصبح أسوأ  بمرور الوقت ، حدث
ما يسمى
بحرائق الزومبي أو حرائق الشتاء
في بيئات خطوط العرض العالية
بما في ذلك مناطق ألاسكا
والشمال الغربي لكندا حيث ترتفع
درجة حرارة الأرض بشكل أسرع من
أي مكان آخر تقريبًا على الرغم من أن معظم حرائق الغابات
تحدث في غضون عام واحد.
تربة غنية
معظم الانبعاثات الناتجة عن هذه الحرائق
لا تأتي من الأشجار وهي
صورة
لدى عامة الناس من حريق غابة
ولكن في تلك المنطقة الأحيائية
في القطب الشمالي والشمال ، يأتي حوالي 90
من الانبعاثات في المتوسط
لتربة من أجل  في المرة الأولى
التي تمكن العلماء من تحديد
عدد حرائق الشتاء
وكيفية العثور عليها التي
استخدمها الباحثون  بيانات من رجال الإطفاء
وتوصلوا إلى خوارزمية لتحديد موقع
هذه الحرائق ،
قدرت أنه بين عامي 2002 و 2018
كان متوسط حوالي واحد بالمائة من حر
ئق الغابات في ألاسكا وش
ال غرب كندا بسبب حر
ئق الشتاء ول
ن في عام 2008 كان أحد حرائق الزومبي مسؤولاً عن
دمير 38 بالمائة  من المنطقة المحترقة
على الرغم من أن الأعداد الإجمالية لهذه
الأنواع من الحرائق
صغيرة ، يقول الباحثون إنها تزداد
احتمالية بسبب تغير المناخ ،
تؤدي درجات الحرارة الأكثر دفئًا إلى ظروف أكثر جفافاً
ومواسم حرائق أطول يقول
مؤلفو الدراسة إن القدرة
على تحديد
مكان هذه الزومبي  الحرائق هي المفتاح
لمساعدة رجال الإطفاء على توقع
اندلاع التفجيرات
وتخصيص مواردهم ،
تعد حرائق الزومبي مجرد واحدة من العديد
من آثار تغير المناخ ،
ولكن كما تظهر هذه الدراسة ،
يحاول العلماء بذل قصارى
جهدهم لتخفيف الضرر توم ساتر سي إن أتلانتا